[Music]
hello odd LODs listeners of course
normally we release new episodes on
Monday but today we're bringing you a
special midweek episode that's because
it's very timely one obviously a lot of
interest in the coronavirus and the
effect that it's having on supply chains
around the world so we didn't want to
wait we didn't want to slot it in future
in the schedule wanted to get it out now
and hopefully
[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
the odd Lots podcast I'm Joe Wiesenthal
and I'm Tracy Holloway Tracy you know
what's really struck me in the markets
over the last several weeks go on
well obviously the crisis over the
coronavirus continues to be this massive
story for the global economy for China
Asia all kinds of different companies
and yet investors in a weird way outside
of some specific names or specific
currencies still seem surprisingly or
maybe not surprisingly but generally not
that worried right now yeah I find this
pretty amazing so at the time that we're
recording I think the S&P 500 is still
pretty close to its all-time high and
what amazes me about that is we spent
two years collectively worrying about
how trade tensions between the US and
China we're going to affect global
supply chains and economic growth and
consumption and we sort of followed
every tiny in and out when it came to
the trade negotiations and now when you
have something
the corona virus and the containment
efforts underway in China you have
something that is guaranteed to impact
production and consumption in the
world's second-biggest economy as well
as disrupt a bunch of supply chains and
no one seems to care yeah it's really
odd it's really surprising it's
counterintuitive it's not what I would
have guessed even this week the week
that we're recording it we got a warning
from one of the sort of emblems of
us-china trade globalization Apple which
is heavily exposed to China on the
supply chain front and heavily exposed
to China on the revenue front saying
look this quarter is going to be worse
than we previously expected factories
aren't opening up for our suppliers as
fast as we had anticipated a couple of
weeks ago we're not totally sure when
things will be back to normal not to
mention the fact that people are out
less shopping
and you know the stock fell about two
percent in the immediate wake of that
maybe because people figured this was
the case already and then the next day
the stock immediately basically erased
all of those losses so even a company
coming out and saying you know this is a
serious issue for us even it's not
having that much effect on them right
now I guess people are so confident that
the effects will just be transitory and
everyone well okay but be back to be
back to work eventually yeah and our
colleagues over at Bloomberg
intelligence actually counted up the
number of companies that are talking
about the coronavirus at the moment and
I think they counted something like nine
trillion dollars worth or companies
accounting for nine trillion dollars
worth of market cap have mentioned the
coronavirus but so far we only really
have a handful of them who are issuing
you know the kind of warnings that we
saw from Apple most of them are just
talking about how it's too early to say
that you know they'll get a direct hit
but again frankly watching all of this
go down in in China and in Asia I find
it really difficult to see how global
supply chains would not be impacted at
this point right so obviously look we
don't know what the markets are going to
do and nobody does and we'll just see
what happens but I do think and I did
think in light of that Apple warning we
really need to dive deeper into the
question of supply chains because so
much of the world so much that so many
companies that manufacture anything are
exposed to China or East Asia in some
way and getting some sort of handle on
what the risks are is key and what the
risks of course to the China economy are
going to be that's also key so that's
what we're going to discuss today great
I think that's a good good let's do it
all right we have a really great guest
we've had him on the podcast I think a
couple of times before at least once but
I'm pretty sure twice is Dan Lang he's
an analyst at GAF College Reaganomics
he's talking to us from Beijing he's a
tech analyst really knows a lot about
Manufacturing Chinese supply chains the
interaction with global tech and he'll
walk us through the risks posed by this
virus what we're seeing right now as
well as other risks that maybe people
aren't even thinking about right now
beyond the virus so Dan thank you very
much for joining us thanks very much for
having me on again we've all seen the
images of various cities across China
either quarantined or de facto
quarantined empty streets and so forth
we know that there are numerous
factories that have yet to reopen and
the schedule for that is remains unclear
we got the warning this week from Apple
that this is going to be a hit to their
performance in the current quarter so
that's known what to you based on your
work that you're doing looking at the
industry what you've seen what really
jumps out at you in terms of the
coronavirus hit to China's industrial
economy so I think you've led by saying
I was in a really good way by saying
that basically the market is regretting
all of this off I think there could be
an economics way of thinking about that
and just you know if you assume that the
virus is going to be mostly contained in
this current quarter and now there's
some evidence that that could be the
case and then the Chinese economy will
basically bounce back into the normal
previous trend growth that will be well
expecting there will be some pent up
demand that would be released later on
and it will be a point that quarter but
everything gets back to trend I think
that case could be made for the general
macro economy and that's why most before
not reacting very much but in terms of
electronics I think that story would not
be so simple and that's because
electronics manufacturing is some of
involves most some of the most complex
supply chain ever needs basically a lot
of different components in place in
order to begin production you need a
thousand in line or maybe even a million
in one component all at the right place
and all of those like time and so
if you have this delay which hasn't
really resolved itself guys I think that
can ripple on and cascade on throughout
the supply chain all the way throughout
the rest of the year when it comes to
basically the peak selling season which
is the Christmas season in the u.s. I
think I will flip a lot throughout the
rest of the year how much flexibility is
there when it comes to altering global
supply chains for electronics companies
because you know during the trade
tensions we saw a lot of people talking
about well they'll just move production
from China to Vietnam or to wherever
there was that option but in the current
situation it seems like first of all
you'd have to do it much much more
quickly and secondly no one's really
sure how the virus is going to play out
so you don't necessarily have the
motivation to move production if you're
thinking that it's going to end very
very quickly so how easy is it to to
shift supply chains for electronics
companies it is all pretty difficult and
we have not seen a great deal of
production move overseas as a result of
the u.s. terrorists on Chinese
production we have done certainly seen
some seeing a few marginal products some
things like servers and some things like
wearables move overseas especially to
Vietnam most by the place but in general
it hasn't been a wholesale losing of
supply chain and I think that's a pretty
difficult thing for companies to deal
with on a short-term a manufacturer made
a statement allow those say that you
know the terrorists are something that
we can deal with that's a cost increase
and that's something yes their interview
is predictable and something that we are
able to resolve whereas if we do not
have a lot of parts as the coronavirus
have threatened if we do not have
workers in our factories because they
just are not coming back or we cannot
pass these sanitary checks or quarantine
trucks imposed by the local government
then we don't even have the parts in
place to engage in production so this
much bigger eel talk to us a little bit
more about modern electronic supply
chains and in a sense they're an
absolute marvel because all these
different companies come together and
the logistics are such that companies
can hold very little inventory and and
the key part arrives just in time for
the other company or the other
manufacturer to assemble it into
something and then that goes into
something else and it's this sort of
beautiful Orchestra maybe when it's
working when it's working ideally talk
to us about what you said when you
pointed out look it's not as simple as
just restarting this because it's so
complex it's not just a matter of okay
the switch goes off for a few weeks and
then maybe you just turn it back on
what is that cascading effect you're
talking about and why is it not so
simple to get it going again once a once
you're ready to restart yeah that's
exactly right so basically to really get
production going as a major manufacturer
like Foxconn you need a lot of different
components in place so you need two out
let's say something like a thousand
components in place you need all of the
labor in place also to begin staffing
you need to make sure that all of the
components are arriving on a daily basis
that there is a lot of flow need to make
sure that the components are of pretty
good quality and use it to make sure
that the labor is of good quality and
right now basically none of those
conditions are holding so Foxconn has
not said they're very much about how
many workers have been able to return
our estimate is that something like half
of China's migrant labor force has
arrived back into other factories it's
going to take point a while probably in
March or early April for everyone to get
back into their place and so you know I
think that the larger manufacturers are
probably able to deal with a lot of
these problems so Foxconn in spite of a
lot of bad press that has received over
the last decade it's still the best pain
of the large manufacturers it has the
best working conditions it is just
really large it employs about a million
people in China every year and then the
five other big contract manufacturers in
Taiwan employ about collectively 500,000
so at one point five million people
total working on is just directly on all
types of electronics but especially the
spawn zone and so basically Apple needs
a lot of people in place and it should
be able to hire all of the people that
it needs but is Foxconn is able to hire
in for everyone because it is working
for its largest customer Apple which has
a lot of cash to throw at these problems
and might [ __ ] away the labor from a lot
of the sub assemblers also the component
makers that are supplying good for
Foxconn you put on two lines of people
to actually produce so you know again I
I want to emphasize that it only takes a
few missing parts for the entire supply
chain not to be functional and so there
will be a lot of these gaps out there on
even for Apple Apple every year launches
a new iPhone by q4 that is highly
predictable but even for Apple it is a
pretty hot affair the supply chains are
pretty tight and everything counts
towards q4 and not very many firms have
a few weeks production to lose so my
thought here is that even though large
manufacturers are working for large
consumer electronics companies like
Apple are able to get through this many
smaller companies are going to have a
lot more problems q1 is typically the
time of year where many consumer
electronics companies engage in
prototyping and development with the
with the manufacturers and if the
manufacturers just are have persistent
labor shortages and supply shortages are
going to be dedicating all their people
to their large customers like Apple and
I think the the case would be here that
this year that consumer electronics will
be pretty bad a lot of smaller companies
won't even be able to launch the
products they had hope to launch by the
Christmas season that's that's already
probably
case and it's going to be a stretch even
for Apple could you to us a little bit
more about the labor shortage idea and
how the containment efforts that we've
seen rolled out across China at this
point how those actually impact the way
the labor market functions so China
today has a lot of restrictions in place
in who can go where when I leave my
apartment in Beijing I had to have flash
this little card at these door men who
have our newly set up to exit and enter
the building every three blocks I go
there is someone taking my temperature
to make sure that I am all right
one thing that I'm struck by now is that
the amount of space capacity that China
has brought to bear on this problem is
impressive and also frightening that
China has been able to quarantine
about 16 million people around the
population of Italy and the span of
around 12 hours my thought here is that
China can mobilize its citizens more
quickly than many countries can mobilize
their army and so it is imposing many
sorts of restrictions on labor on even
today many migrants are not able to
enter the large cities to actually begin
production so a lot of the public
transportation in terms of training for
the car shot a lot of loads are a lot of
cars are not able to go on the road and
this is creating a lot of problems for
factories that really need that labor
and I think the biggest issue here is
that there's considerable uncertainty
about when this virus could be declared
eradicated and for everybody to feel
safe to go back to their jobs so these
travel restrictions could evaporate on
let's say next week on their work tape
could take something longer let's take a
month but it will take probably even
longer for all
flights to resume and for all of the
people to feel that they can basically
travel about in China and that will
create a lot of uncertainties there is
just a lot of human contact still
required for to engage in production
yeah and one of the things that we've
seen anecdotally as well is this notion
of a sort of patchwork of local and
national rules so for instance in order
to open up a factory you know local
officials will require the factory owner
to give face masks to all of its workers
but of course there's a giant face mask
shortage and so they're unable to do
that and we've seen a lot of chaos let's
say in confusion when it comes to what
the rules are and what they are not when
it comes to work environments all right
Ken trying to deal with that right
around the holiday and the huge moves
extraordinary Dan is there a compounding
effect of the delays such that okay you
know I know that at one point the goal
is okay reopened by February 10th that
didn't happen in many cases but is there
a sort of non-linearity where a week of
delays does not just mean a week of
problems and each week the the situation
sort of snowballs and grows you know
compounds or grows exponentially yes
there is that risk that there is a lot
nonlinear aspect to this if you were
expecting basically a lot of components
to arrive and if you don't then a lot of
manufacturers could be quite stuck and
for other manufacturers like Foxconn
core at the end of a supply chain is
clean waiting for everybody to send
everything through they don't
necessarily have great visibility into
which little parts are they require that
just doesn't necessarily make it so
every time there's an earthquake in
Japan reminds us reminds the world about
how dependent on the entire world is on
perhaps a particular factory making a
particular widget and so these things
can be a little bit unpredictable but I
think the I think the
large companies like Apple realized that
at this point and I think everybody is
going to be in a scramble in the coming
weeks to really understand how deep the
supply chains are another issue for
Apple right now is that Apple sends a
lot of engineers from its headquarters
in Cupertino to come over to China and
then actually monitor station these
engineers and monitor the progress of
these component makers has for all of
the assurance and products development
purposes a lot of those flights are
cancelled and I expect that Apple is
only able to send a trickle of staff
over to China to actually monitor all of
that production so there are a lot of
these risks out there dad talk to us a
little bit about I guess the big picture
long-term impact when it comes to
China's technology ambitions so I think
the first time we had you on this
podcast was to talk about the made in
China
2025 initiative where China is really
trying to bulk up its own technology
expertise would you expect something
like the corona virus outbreak to have a
long-term impact on those efforts
certainly I think it will a push greater
geographic diversity I think that the
the the the events of the last few years
have shown that companies are highly
dependent on China for production I
think many companies are thinking more
deeply about what geographic diversity
actually means so previously we thought
that geographic diversity you know it's
important in case there's a flood or an
earthquake which are fairly localized
events so if you want to basically have
a more robust supply chain you should
locate a lot of your factories just
geographically quite far away from each
other and I think the events at least of
the last year have shown that when
President Trump has imposed tariffs on
Chinese goods that there is a political
element so even if you produce in
northern China and then southeastern
China you may necessarily you might
still be hit by a lot of these new risks
now whether and how it impacts China's
technology development I think it is
going to make it
little bit more difficult or trying to
do everything that it would like at the
very least it is turning on some
foreigners and expats I lost the idea of
living for most of the time in places
like Beijing and Shanghai and I think
that will be at least a lot of potential
talent that Chinese firms are able to
hire dan I think that's a great
opportunity to sort of segue into
another another risk factor facing
Chinese manufacturing Chinese supply
chain because it was just a few months
ago that there was this thought that
okay the big risk was just on the trade
front that seems to have cleared up they
got the phase 1 deal now suddenly
there's this which is you know as you
point could potentially change
everything or at least change really
changed the way companies around the
world think about their exposure to
China but as you point out and as you've
been writing the coronavirus is really
not the only major threat to Chinese
supply chains Chinese manufacturing and
that there is another thing lurking out
there that people need to pay attention
to so what is that so that is the
current US policy on how to restrict
technology flows to China and so there
as part of the trade war there has also
been a bit of a tech war hovering in the
background in terms of US policy action
I think the first major shot of that was
last year or almost a year and a half
ago now when president crown
administration designated ZTE to
something called the deny Christmas list
which more or less cut off disease and
higher ability to procure from American
technology especially semiconductors and
so that has brought the firm to its
knees almost the verge of bankruptcy and
fill a presidency and crump
reached a political solution to save the
company there has been this element
hovering in the background of the u.s.
exercising investment restriction
on the ability of foreigners to invest
in US firms especially technology firms
that have been a process initiated by
the Department of Justice to scrutinize
Chinese actions much more closely in
terms of trade secrets appropriation but
also Chinese activities and they
universities working with certain
professors and then it has also
manifested and specifically this issue
of always becoming a large player in the
tech world and then the administration
is thinking much more carefully now
about how to deny products American
products to a firm that it considers a
national security threat what would be
the impact on China's tech industry if
the u.s. does actually go through with a
lot of the things that it's threatening
and what options does China have to
offset the impact of those curves
I can see issue right now for China is
to figure out how to Americanize supply
chain so again this is sort of a supply
chain story in which a lack of a few
components can really defeat the system
so if you take a look at your smartphone
it has something like 1,500 different
components in it and if you lack even
three or four different components the
whole system might just be defeated so
your phone needs for example a battery
it is a processor the memory chips and
it needs a screen but if you don't have
these other you don't really have a
phone and given that the US has figured
out that it is almost a monopolist on
very important technologies especially
the semiconductor and like denying us
semiconductors to particular firms
previously ege this figured out it can
really [ __ ] China technology
advancements now I take the view that
over the long term
ajayan evidence realized that it's very
dependent on US technologies it should
be able to figure out a lot of
technologies on in turn so it's
difficult to name in history a country
that has monopolized the key
over the long term so in the 18th
century when the UK was the leading
industrial power at the time and when
they tried to export control certain
textile mills and generate to the u.s.
rising power certain people just
memorized a bunch of mill design gone
onto a ship and then went to the US so
one of these people is Samuel Slater
who's known in the UK as later the
creator and they v as the father of the
US Industrial Revolution a lot of
knowledge just consists in people's head
and transfers I used to work in Silicon
Valley the same that we had there was
that knowledge travels of his beat of
beer a beer or coffee pick your poison
and so long as you can just talk through
these sort of things and a lot of
Technology is able to travel the Chinese
don't have to invent anything de novo
they only have to replicate existing
processes but that is still a pretty big
cow the u.s. is basically a monopolist
and bringing peace and acceptor
technologies including the capital
equipment to actually other gauges any
conductors and also in things like
aviation engines in which China is also
kind of catch up so this is why there
has been a pretty active debate in the
white house on how to actually restrict
a lot more technologies to China while
also being able to protect the ability
of US firms to sell goods to their
largest markets and then also generating
revenue for greater re it's so
interesting just sort of thinking about
the symmetry or the asymmetry or I guess
it's the symmetry of the needs and
priorities of China when it comes to
trade and the needs and priorities of
the US when it comes to trade obviously
we know President Trump feels that they
would like to bring back jobs from China
and maybe you know it's debatable
whether anything that's been done so far
I would really accomplish that obviously
that was a key driving aspect of his
campaign and his message and so forth
and then you have the Chinese economy
and the or the Chinese priorities that
you've talked to us on the podcast
before and it's not about jobs per se
it's about the
Alliance and you know winning back the
tech tech war against the US so it's
really sort of the same thing in a sense
of both just wanting to not need the
other yeah that's right
so both countries on constitutes the
upper preserves and Technology which is
right now mostly an American affair and
the Chinese also wanting many of the
same thing so I guess then my question
is you know obviously in the first half
of the conversation you were talking
about okay US companies are going to
think about geographic diversity for
manufacturing and of course during the
trade war we heard a lot about Vietnam
but there's really no country
immediately that can just suddenly
absorb a huge influx of new demand for
manufacturing I mean there's just all
kinds of things that need to go into
that it's not like you just build a
Foxconn in Vietnam overnight or a
Foxconn and Brazil overnight or anything
like that who wins the race like how
long say will it take for China to
accomplish what it needs on sort of you
know being able to design some of its
own semiconductors so that it can wean
itself off of US tech that's a great
question thinking about it in terms of a
race and I tend to think that the US has
the advantage here it is a lot more
straightforward for Apple to move most
of its supply chain out of China and to
let's say a mix of places that include
India Brazil and Vietnam than it is for
China to figure out semiconductors which
are the most complex technologies in the
world when I think of something like a
semiconductor manufacturing equipment
from a firm like a SML basically these
pieces of machinery are about as large
as buses each machine costs about 200
million US dollars and you're really
playing with light and physics and that
at that point it's almost like a pure
science affair the Chinese just have not
had enough experience really doing a lot
of these things now they're the
then becomes when the u.s. exercises
these export control actions on China
does it accelerate China's technology
development or does it really [ __ ] it
I think over the long term it should
still be accelerating China's technology
development so right now these you know
the trends have always had a program to
replace its own internal the
technologies that it uses with Chinese
made equipment part of that has that has
always been a program and has somewhat
accelerated in 2013 after the Snowden
revelations of different spying and I
think the Chinese now are this is the
difference in the last two years is that
this is no longer a whimsical government
effort which has never really been
terribly successful in the past now this
is what much more by private company by
firms like Alibaba or 10 cents were
hikvision or sell me that are asking
themselves can I depend on American
supply such that I'm willing to build
off my build my technology off in
Americans back for the next 10 years and
they are becoming a little bit more
hesitant to do something like that
and so they are taking the lead and kind
of develop if they're a more homegrown
more politically dependable component so
Dan just to sum it all up I'm kind of
curious to get some of your personal
observations about the situation at the
moment what has surprised you about how
the coronavirus or the containment
efforts around the corona virus have
impacted either the tech industry or the
electronics industry what was most
surprising I think the speed and scale
of the payment efforts I think after
Luhan was quarantine first of all day
quarantine Ojai really quickly and
basically there has been a really
enormous demonstration of state power
here
ah state capacity here I think are now
trying to figure out given that there
are some encouraging signs that the
virus is abating the number of
infections a cuvette has been in the
double digits I think for the last three
days meaning that the epidemic seems to
be mostly contained in in Hebei and
Wuhan and the question now is really how
to restart the economy so they have been
really good at making sure that people
are in their place and that the state
has the ability to quarantine very many
people now I think interesting point to
watch is how quickly they can reverse a
lot of these restrictions - well
everyone's fears and then restart the
economy because a lot of things are just
halted now well Dan really appreciate
you joining us always love chatting with
you and we should probably you know do
one again maybe in three months or six
months and just sort of reassess where
things are on the supply chain and the
degree to which the industrial economy
has been able to come back but Dan thank
you and hope everything returns to some
semblance of normalcy fairly soon thanks
very much chef thank you so much it's
really good
[Music]
so Joe I found that conversation really
really interesting it's nice to dig deep
into the supply chain issue and I do
think there seems to be a sense out
there that they can be very flexible and
they can be reoriented as needed but as
Dan pointed out they they're actually
quite complex and it takes time to move
these things now there are so many
things that he pointed out that I hadn't
seen anyone discuss before thinking
about so for example okay Christmas
shopping or holiday electronic sales
that seems like a long time from now but
if the basic prototyping of the next
generation of any products is Q 1 and Q
1 is looking like for sure a total
disaster then okay even if there is a
big economic rebound in q2 which we
don't know for sure yet but even if
there is there will be inevitably this
cascading effect that lasts at least
through the year and that to some extent
there is no getting back this lost time
yeah and the other thing I've been
thinking about is we you know we were
just speaking about the production side
of things but you would think that the
corona virus outbreak is going to end up
having a very very large impact on
consumption as well so China is
basically in for both a supply and
demand shock to its economy and I also
wonder when it comes to the consumption
decline how long is that going to last
and is it going to be similar like
supply chains in that it takes a while
to get back to normal you know the
Chinese government has spent so long
telling people that they really need to
make efforts to contain the virus they
have to stay at home is it going to be
easy for them to lift those and suddenly
tell everyone Oh everything's back to
normal you don't need to worry anymore
to Dan's point in the last question yeah
totally because you know there's
obviously there's no cure there's no
vaccine that we have or anything like
that yet so to declare victory over the
virus or to declare that it's been
eradicated seems like an extremely
difficult thing and even after you know
people start coming back
to work it seems plausible that fear of
a new outbreak or fear of just one
person having it and spreading into a
new super spreader situation could
really change how people behave at least
for quite some time after you know after
whatever that the idea of any sort of
imminent resident resumption of normal
life it kind of seems implausible
there's so much going on it's such an
interesting story and really sort of
unprecedented in in many ways so what a
fascinating topic to talk about hearing
Dan talk about how there's someone who
checks checks his temperature literally
every three blocks and as he pointed out
the state capacity required simply to
set that up I mean it's just
extraordinary to think about what they
what has been done already yeah they're
doing it in Hong Kong as well they're
not quite on that scale but certainly to
get into the major office buildings at
the moment you have to get your
temperature taken so it's a big change
this has been another episode of the odd
lots podcast I'm Tracy Holloway you can
follow me on Twitter at JC Holloway and
I'm Jill Wiesenthal you can follow me on
Twitter at the stalwart and you should
follow our producer on Twitter
laura carlson she's at Laura M Carlson
as well as the Bloomberg head of
podcasts Francesca levy at Francesca
today and check out all of the bloomberg
podcasts under the handle at podcasts
thanks for listening
[Music]
you